alors que les députés de la france
insoumise remettent en cause le modèle
néolibéral la crise sanitaire s'apprête
à laisser place à la crise économique
nous allons souffrir sur le front de
l'emploi prévient emmanuel macron le pib
a déjà plongé de 6% au premier trimestre
2001 la france est entrée en récession
alors question faut-il travailler plus
pour sauver l'économie de notre pays
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec benjamin ma membres du
bureau confédéral de la cgt
benjamin marquis est un cadre un du
syndicat bonsoir à vous philippe herlin
ses côtés pour en débattre économistes
vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
dont pouvoir d'achat le grand mensonge
aux éditions eyrolles
bonsoir également avoue philippe herlin
alors c'est un pavé dans la mare lancé
par le patron du medef le 11 avril
dernier je rappelle les termes il faudra
travailler un peu plus afin de relancer
l'économie
à mois plus tard nous avons donc entamé
un vous le savez je vous le rappelle pas
le déconfinement avec la crise
économique qui nous guette cette
déclaration geoffroy de geoffroy roux de
bézieux est-ce qu'elle était
prémonitoire
selon vous philippe herlin il va falloir
travailler plus il faut travailler plus
mais pas seulement il faut aussi que il
sera plus intéressant de travailler en
france c'est à dire qu'il faut diminuer
leur charge fiscale qui pèse sur les
entreprises
il faut bien comprendre que le
coronavirus c'est pas la cause de la
crise avant le coronavirus la france
allait déjà mal y avait du chômage y
avait des failles et d'entreprises les
shows il y avait une très faible
croissance et donc il faut le
coronavirus a joué un rôle de
déclencheur en quelque sorte mais si ça
n'avait pas été le corps n'avait russie
aurait eu un autre choc externe qui
aurait pu déstabiliser l'économie de la
même façon donc il faut moi je suis
convaincu il faut s'attacher aux
problèmes structurels de l'économie
française donc un niveau d'impôts trop
élevé je rappelle que le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires en france est
le plus élevé des pays de l' ocde
il ya aussi la complexité fiscale c'est
extrêmement complexe et c'est d'autant
plus content
ex pour les pme les grands groupes qui
peuvent se payer des fiscalistes mais
les pme les tpe ils peuvent pas et ça
c'est une prise de tête incroyable
il ya aussi le changement régulier des
impôts qui fait tousser variabilité
cette volatilité de l'impôt est aussi
complexe
voilà il ya aussi un code du travail qui
est bien trop complexe et donc il faut
s'attaquer à cela maintenant pour
pouvoir avoir une véritable reprise
économique en france
sinon on aura pas de reprise en u même
pas on aura une reprise en l c'est à
dire que on mettra des années peut-être
dix ans a retrouvé le niveau de
croissance qu'on avait en 2019
benjamin a marre je vous sent bouillir d
un taux des impôts trop élevés en france
une réforme du code de travail on
imagine que vous n'êtes pas du tout
d'accord non je ne suis pas du tout en
colère je suis habitué au juke box crié
des libéraux vous inquiétez pas je ne
suis pas du bureau de confédérale de la
cgt je fais partie de la commission
exécutive confédérale
vous m'avez donné du galon
supplémentaire mais proprement pour
revenir sur le sujet pour revenir sur le
sujet les déclarations de monsieur roux
de bézieux ne sont pas prémonitoire
c'est révélateur d'une situation en
france quand le président du medef
chanter une comptine et vient derrière
vous avez le coeur des vestales qui
reprend régulièrement cette petite
musique
nous avons eu l'institut montaigne
aujourd'hui monsieur airs là mais
écoutez c'est quand même incroyable
c'est à dire moi je trouve que c'est une
mentalité de charognards c'est à dire
que vous avez une crise sanitaire
incroyable et certains mais finalement
comme seul argument alors que les
français vivent une situation terrible
de l'art et va falloir travailler plus
c'est quand même très étonnant
je vais donner des idées aux libéraux
français en nouvelle-zélande
la première ministre jasmine garden en
train de proposer aux ailes exactement
inverse c'est à dire de baisser le temps
de travail en proposant la création de
jour férié en proposant la semaine de
quatre jours en se disant que justement
eh ben ça va permettre de doubler par
exemple le secteur touristique
mais où est donc cette petite cette
petite chanson qui est complètement à
rebours de l'histoire sociale
l'histoire sociale ça a été la baisse du
temps de travail pour obtenir des gains
de productivité en plus
ce qui est sidérant quand même c'est de
nous dire qu'il faut augmenter le temps
de travail au moment même où les plans
sociaux s'annonce à l'horizon de notre
façon de plus en plus menaçante chez
renault chez conforama mais également
dans plein d'autres secteurs chez alinéa
dans leur entreprise comme smith lâcher
car guil ces luttes ce faire on a
effectivement des risques de plans
sociaux qui se présentait la cgt
d'ailleurs partout interpelle pour dire
attention il faut conserver notre tissu
industriel parce que on a bien vu au
moment de masquer des tests et des
réparateurs que notre puissance
industrielle est à nu à cause de
délocalisation à cause de cette façon de
brader notre patrimoine industriel et
enfin l'argument de la fiscalité est
incroyable mais monsieur guerlain
je ne sais pas s'ils étaient dans un
abri anti atomique
pendant la crise nous notre notre modèle
social qui permet de financer par
exemple activité partielle
ce qui nous plaît impact social quand on
voit ce qui se passe aux etats-unis par
exemple eh bien il est financé par
justement cette fiscalité la fiscalité
elle finance la solidarité elle finance
justement notre modèle social
le seul problème dans notre fiscalité
c'est effectivement la trop faible
fiscalité sur le capital et l'évasion
fiscale massive
ça ce sont des problèmes mais
visiblement on n'a pas les mêmes
diagnostic de façon très étonnante
philippe avant de revenir sur ses 35
heures parce que je voudrais vous faire
écouter justement les députés france
insoumise méthyle panneaux sur ce point
une petite réponse sur cette dernière
remarque de benjamin marc le problème
c'est l'évasion fiscale en france
attention c'est plus ça c'est un mythe
l'évasion fiscale il n'y a pas de
chiffres sérieux vraiment qui circulent
là dessus il ya évidemment l'évasion
fiscale parce que la france est à
l'enfer fiscal iaa taux d'imposition qui
découragent les gens donc donc les gens
aucune envie de partir il faut le
comprendre il ya des paradis fiscaux il
ya beaucoup de qualité sont qui sont en
fait des pays comme une fiscalité
normale c'est pour ça que les gens y
vont il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
s'installer en belgique parce qu'il n'ya
pas un impôt sur la fortune ou dix
filles où ils vont s'installer en suisse
voilà la france est un enfer fiscal non
faut pas s'étonner que les gens partent
la meilleure façon de les garder c'est
d'avoir une spécialité qui soit dans la
norme française voilà
spécialité sur les personnes créer une
fiscalité sur les entreprises
seule entreprise par exemple on sépare
et je lisais petits qu'aujourd'hui il ya
les impôts sur la production qui
paissent l'équivalent de 3 2% de pib
c'est le double de niveau européen
allemagne 0,4 pour cent les impôts sur
la production ça veut dire que on taxe
pas les bénéfices un tacle de chiffre
d'affaires même si vous faites beaucoup
de bénéfices ou très peu de bénéfices
vous avez la même taxe et ses liens au
chiffre d'affaires et ça et ça ça
s'appelle sur l'entreprise et c'est
presque une prime à la délocalisation et
on le voit aujourd'hui avec renault qui
doit fermer six usines pour les mettre à
l'extérieur voilà donc il faut il faut
s'attaquer à ces problèmes il faut
s'attaquer à ces problèmes et c'est pas
avec plus d'étapes on va s'en sortir
voilà alors pour revenir sur ce sujet
des 35 heures parce que c'est un petit
peu le débat travailler plus pour
relancer l'économie mise à mal notamment
par sept prix du co vide 19 je voudrais
vous faire écouter donc mathilde pas nos
députés france insoumise qui plaide pour
aller plus loin encore que ce fait 35
heures on va avoir une explosion du
chômage donc face à l'explosion du
chômage il ne faut pas faire travailler
des gens toujours plus mais au contraire
diminuer le temps de travail la création
des 35 heures est un des moments qui a
eu le plus de créations d'emplois dans
notre histoire naissante il faut
diminuer le temps de travail pour
pouvoir travailler tout et tout
benjamin a marre vous avez parfois les
encore plus loin et travailler encore
moins que les 35 heures en qu'ils
évoquent
chez les filles 32 heures ça a été un
des moments d'espoir qui a créé le plus
d'emplois qu'on est d'accord avec ce
diagnostic
benjamin amarres avant de faire réagir
philippe herlin alors d'abord j'aimerais
juste réagir ce qui pèse sur les
entreprises
c'est bien plus la le l'impérieuse
nécessité de verser des dividendes aux
actionnaires
je rappelle que la france est championne
du monde dans la roche des dividendes
aux actionnaires et qu'elle obtient
chaque année des résultats plus probants
la matière les riches vont très bien et
il n'y a pas de problème pour le capital
qui justement se rétribue plus que gras
sur les 35 heures après janvier
exactement des cafés maintenant je vous
rappelle que et la cgt le porte à
plusieurs reprises de philippe martinez
ans
a fait état dans les médias la cgt porte
le modèle de la réduction du temps de
travail à 32 heures
bien évidemment mais avec ce triptyque
qui consiste à dire travailler plus
travailler mieux travailler moins bien
sûr qu'il est absurde de vouloir faire
travailler davantage ce qui déjà
travaille beaucoup
alors qu'on a un chômage important
l'histoire sociale elle a consisté
encore une fois je le répète à faire
baisser le temps de travail ce qui
permet de lutter contre le chômage et
d'obtenir des gains de productivité bien
évidemment n'en déplaise aux libéraux
pour qui les 35 heures sont responsables
de tout y compris de la disparition des
dinosaures
en réalité les 35 heures ont été le
moment où on a créé le plus massivement
d'emplois ces trente dernières années
à chaque fois que le patronat a demandé
des exonérations de cotisations eh bien
pour soi disant derrière doper l'emploi
et bien il ne s'est il sait il ne s'est
rien passé
souvenez-vous du petit pin's de monsieur
gattaz au moment du pacte de
responsabilité avec marc et un million
d'emplois créés et quand michel sapin
ministre de l'économie de l'époque le
v10 c'est une promesse monsieur battage
monsieur gattaz avait répondu non c'est
un pin's voilà donc si on veut créer des
emplois effectivement on baisse le temps
de travail la cgt portent cette
revendication très précise des 32 heures
philippe herlin votre réponse mais la
rue la baisse du temps de travail
aujourd'hui c'est serait ce qui pourra
les pires l'économie française parce que
déjà qu'ils ont reprise ont subi un choc
énorme et que le quoran à virus
si les salariés travaillent 32 heures
payées 35 ou payer 39
ça va faire encore augmenter les coûts
par les entreprises essam a précipité
dans la faillite des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises donc ce serait
une catastrophe absolue donc on met là
on voit on se demande on ne voit que la
cgt qui se définit comme révolutionnaire
alors une société qui veut détruire une
organisation qui veut détruire la
société démocratique et libérale que
nous avons moi je considère que aussi la
réalisation de la france a réussi sa
passe par la résolution sera pas servi
ça passe par la réduction du pouvoir des
syndicats en france et pas réparé par là
il parle des vraies libertés syndicales
afin de limiter un certain nombre de
centrales il faut une vraie liberté
syndicale
et il faut baisser une petite diminution
des nuisances des syndicats qui perçoit
des roulades yannick sandouville
on l'avait on l'a vu on l'avait rixe en
double le renault sont deux villes car
ferme et non pas pour des raisons
sanitaires mais pour des questions mais
parce que la convocation avait été
envoyé par email plutôt que par courrier
c'est voilà voilà la victoire de la cgt
ou à je dis bravo on peut applaudir à
rabat une belle victoire est une belle
victoire contre l'empoignent contre
l'entreprise française
donc moi je n'ai qui a strictement rien
à attendre d'un sale et qu'un
révolutionnaire qui veut détruire la
société démocratique et libérale et que
la rieuse radiation ça passera notamment
entre autres par la réduction du pouvoir
des syndicats et par une vraie de
légèreté syndicale qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui en france
le mot de la fin pour benjamin marque
hummer dans vie je voulais vous faire
réagir également sur ses ces jours
fériés que certains parlent de supprimer
mais je vous ai tellement bavasse tous
les yeux qu on aura le temps va jamais à
les y réponde et les désirs de nos cieux
herlin sont amusants mais pas content il
se de la fecq nous c'est monsieur
guerlain
vous allez me communiquer votre adresse
mail on va vous envoyer le jugement de
sandouville ne vous n'avez pas lu il y a
des choses très précises dans ce
jugement là le l'entreprise a été
condamnée par le juge du référé parce
que au lieu de faire une simple
information
elle devait convoquer en bonne et due
forme le cs le juge du référé a
également considéré que les élus du
personnel n'avaient pas du tout les
mêmes comment dire les bons éléments
pour appréhender la sécurité sanitaire
donc ce mythe des libéraux qui consiste
à dire est qu'il y avait également de la
situation et des merlus 10 et tables qui
n'était pas bien arrivé ce sont des
mensonges
monsieur google de la face à nous
affirmer comme entendu ce que vous avez
dit sur le paradis qui sport on comprend
bien qu avec vous la vérité est toujours
dans le placard de viella je précise
merci j'ai profité d'un petit blanc
c'était pas facile
merci à tous les deux benjamins 1 marc
philippe herlin d'avoir été avec nous et
débattre chacun de vos idées on vous
mettra évidemment pas d'accord mais
enfin c'est le but des face-à-face merci
en tout cas à tous les deux